I know you're gonna do something hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to theater unrest this is a game
that is about a very specific
creepypasta that we probably all know
because there's been a couple games made
about it already and it's about a
theatre that is not just haunted but it
is possessed in a way that traps you in
a dimension that you can never escape
from so that you're perpetually stuck in
a hell of your own making which is cool
I guess if you're into that sort of
thing but this is the newest game about
it I don't know if it's exactly about
the creepypasta or if it's like an
evolution on the concept but either way
we're going into a theater or what
happens if I don't take the ticket what
happens if I leave the ticket it kind of
said death on it I don't know if that's
the kind of ticket that I'm gonna enjoy
I'm wondering if that's kind of ticket
that's gonna end up with me being dead
oh hi how are you good to see you I
don't have a ticket I'm gonna barge in
here and I'm gonna watch it bootlegs
style and there's not a damn thing you
can do to stop me
hi well this is a comfortable engagement
leonidas but you know you need to get
back to Sparta and I got to get into
this movie theater alright okay how's
the Queen
all right knock off markiplier will see
how you deal with me once I get my
ticket of death I give you the ticket
death that means you get the death and
it does not go to me that's how the law
works yeah yeah oh don't leave your
ticket only I got it okay one ticket to
death hello oh hey how's it going good
to see ya I love the way your eyes
pierce the darkness before I see any
features of your body you know a ticket
thank you please enjoy the movie okay I
will thank you which one's my theater do
I just wander around and guess oh it's a
long hallway you know they say the
cinema industry is dying you know not
many people go into theaters you know
maybe if you didn't overcharge for
concessions it would no this is a dead
end
I see I must have missed my theater
somewhere ordinarily they put movie
posters in these poster holders whatever
you'd call the frames they'd be movie
posters in the frames seems like you
guys don't do that here I like it you're
original ah okay this must have been my
theater oh yes sorry that's a wall oh
well I don't like the butter stains on
the chairs hi how you doing
[Music]
are you expecting me to memorize that or
something because
[Music]
[Music]
all right well I'm not too much into
slam poetry but that was lovely good
take the ticket you know what I'm gonna
take the ticket
Oh whither that was not the second was
that the second symbol that showed up I
can't even remember what the symbols
were they were all different circles and
axes and shapes I can't remember things
like that alien itis hey how you doing
here's an electic thank you what please
enjoy the movie I heard something to my
right I definitely heard something to my
right camera blessed my right wait no I
was in well I guess it's a different
movie so should be expected that it's a
different theater I heard something my
left I definitely heard something to my
left your right my left also who's this
other dude that's watching this movie
with me
what is this cat's only two people are
gonna watch it yep wither death wither
whatever that is king
hmm no I can't see
[Music]
when were you in school you are yet
[Music]
[Music]
hey I am content hey I make good content
baby hey where's my ticket
I can't possibly move forward without my
ticket
Leonidas ain't gonna let me go he said
none shall pass
what too much stale popcorn hi can I can
I see a movie please just blink if you
don't want me to barge by that's
disturbing just the random noises around
me that's horrifying
I don't need stop it whoever's doing
that whoever's thinks they're clever
enough to do that to me you need to cut
that [ __ ] out anybody got a ticket here
anybody found a ticket maybe I could dig
through the trash get a ticket oh wait a
minute this is open I'll give up oh my I
don't know what I'm gonna get back
nothing turns out it was a trap turns
out I am The Fool Oh lurk hmm death with
her
zurk look I get to see the movie lurk
stop that [ __ ] immediately thank you for
saying that with a little more speed
alright so where is lurk death with
lurk fine good all great for me
good stuff indeed is my friend still
there there's my friend how are you
doing friend good see you mm-hmm
death with a lurk King scoop no my
pothole
[Music]
Oh
why would someone do that
mildly disconcerting you your poems seem
to cut me to my core there's a rumble in
my tumbly my tumbly seems to be rumbly
that was not the rumbly mind well okay
that wait a minute what I didn't know
that that was something that actually be
worried about I thought it was as a
person who was in trouble right so I'm
gonna show who hey bud how you doing
okay listen listen listen strafe running
is the way to go
that's what I do and that's what I know
you think yeah you think Leonidas is
gonna tolerate your [ __ ] he'll be oh
well then jeezum Christmas criminy
crackers this game is interesting
Leonidas please enjoy thank you death
wither lurk mine you know the four basic
food groups so is mr. sobs a lot gonna
come come and find me is that the other
guy in this theater besides me lots in
these shouldn't have seen such a sad
movie no he's gone hey hey mister sobs a
lot death loser
look whoa
well hog swoop no in my butthole
I'm hearing a lot
[Music]
rip it down oh my god
[Music]
this is oddly sexual there's real sexual
I don't know if I appreciate how sexual
it is there's that rumbly in my tumbly
good was hoping that would be there
because if it wasn't going to be there I
was going to be mad take my ticket is
mr. sobs log gonna be we would a sorrow
oh yeah sorry oh yeah you're not even
here yeah I'm coming for you yeah I'm
coming for you you you in here oh this
is sorrow okay so death with her lurk
mind there was probably enough sorrow I
think it was death with her lurk mine
sorrow oh well well hi hi how are you
alright cool good glad we have this
conversation hey you stay there and you
don't move because almost like leonidas
on you hey Leo Leo baby Leo baby
I've come to see some sorrow you got any
sadness thank you please enjoy the movie
well that was oddly cheerful and then my
rumbly in my tumbly do something about
your voice Leonidas Sujatha always sets
me at ease let's go fine probably fine
it's all good thankfully if you think
about it
I don't like it it's fine
it's all good so good actually well that
is that is strange must be the basement
theater hi how are you
you in here
want to skip them a little peekaboo
there you are
let me see you move here my I've already
forgotten death
mind lurk butthole I can't remember
ads I did not give consent
[Music]
okay love pickup oh no oh no evil yeah
you guys having a power outage maybe I
should come back just such a cinephile
love me some cinema oh hi how are you
lady yeah I know I look good when I'm
walking away
well that's unnecessary that's a little
peculiar that whole thing moved closer
with you always like that okay it's fine
Leonidas baby hey good to see ya how you
yeah never leave your posts do you thank
you please enjoy I will and thank you
for your service
I appreciate you well I didn't like that
whatever that was I don't need to go
check you know that's the thing I've
just learned about myself is that I
actually don't need to go check I in
fact don't want to go check going
checking would be the last thing that I
would actually want to do so I won't do
it I'm doing yeah I am perfectly okay
with non going and checking whatever
that was just gonna see a movie already
forgotten what the names are that's okay
the power works in here you're much
closer than I have hoped you would be
you're very close very close
there's no need there is no need there's
no need keep your eye on the movie
please
what the fool I don't want to touch it
[Music]
okay alright well if I'm a flying what
does that make you you talking about
touching these doors cuz maybe I could
touch me but maybe I don't want to maybe
I want to see a movie you ever think
about that
rebirth all right
sure looks like someone's saying no to
their butt hole but rebirth will go with
that
oh great great great mm-hmm all right
Leo baby Leone my gosh
Leo there's my man there's my main man
that's my main man how you doing
large mind sorrow you rebirth
okay all right I'm not gonna question
that that seemed like a perfectly normal
exchange love the interior decor though
this is delightful everything about this
screams freaking snow back up now all
I've decided I've seen enough movies
seven in a row seven in a row not for me
not for me decided I want to actually
I'm fine this is fine what's one more
give me another bag of popcorn give me a
do give me a big old do
oh my buddy's in there I missed my pow
someone sobbing oh hey now that seems
inappropriate
whatever you're doing wait what what
just happened what happened I don't know
what happened I'm not sure what happened
I've been reborn leonidas how you doing
you good ah yes I'm gonna go back
how long until I just realized I'm in
purgatory forever and I'm never gonna
get out in any way hi
are you doing hello baby
did you miss me I love your smile
this is gonna be one of those like you
pointed something on my shirt and you
blank me right on the nose isn't it you
are glowing
you're vibrant right just shining like a
beacon alright okay thank you ma'am
I'll just be on my way you uh you have a
nice day okay here you take care of
yourself now hear around alright it's
tough Leo baby Leo I'm just gonna assume
that I died and I did something wrong so
I'm just gonna try that again
[Music]
[Music]
you got me there big guy you got me
there you're yeah you you okay
okay
all right well just be on my way
hmm it's really fine it's all fine
completely fine hmm oh hey how you doing
there
oh yeah big baby baby baby whoo we all
gotta do hi
our young uh how are you you good Hey
I did not expect that
mm-hmm gonna grab this and run lean on
us hold
oh [ __ ] oh well that's not good that's
fine totally fine what wait there's
something behind you Leo thank you
please enjoy all right cool
good hey how you doing how you doing are
you doing well I should have known I
should have known Oh wasn't that was a
mistake
this game doesn't faze me I'm a story
that is trying to tell it's falling on
deaf ears thank you thank you please
enjoy the movie hi how you doing
whatever I'll go after yourself all
right well that's a problem all right I
sure that clown who is big you
take me out you faked me out I thought
mm-hmm
they thought oh okay
you're gonna turn the lights out and
think that I'm gonna be spooked by this
where is my ticket oh I know
ticket hi how you doing
thanks all right I've got a tingle who
is that oh hey how you doing boo boo oh
I see how it is okay all right what am I
supposed to believe that the Slenderman
is back here yeah okay all right Lou I
will thank you okay I'm gonna leave you
to your own devices yeah I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna mess with that fool me
once shame on me fool me twice
whoa call me twice shame on you hey I
get to go down the long long it's
definitely closed off still down there
right yeah I get to go down the long
long
oh hi lady Hey you mind stepping out of
the way hey one way only one way only
one way only lady one way only
okay ma'am ma'am ma'am hey leo guess
who's got a big shiny golden ticket for
you to tear in half I know how much you
love to do that Leo I am here to make
sure you are pleased all right
there's nothing bunch of baloney a bunch
of malarkey some Malhar Cologne II hope
I get to go down the long long now well
that's unfortunate
oh you're not supposed to be here you're
supposed to be in the gray well all
right then problem what are you gonna do
you gonna do something I know you're
gonna do something you gonna do
something oh it's fine
it's all good baby yeah okay I guess we
got no ticket
- Leo Leo's gone what leo go new alert
Oh whither sorry whither lurk mind lurk
mind main sorrow sorrow Ribera Oh Oh No
I haven't earned rebirth then is that
what you're trying to tell me I have yet
to earn rebirth probably is the case
probably is exactly what they're trying
to tell me but alas I am too stupid to
actually understand it evil God about
evil Oh thought I saw something turns
out I did not but I'm finally going down
the long long sorrow sorrow
okay I guess movie passes expiring love
that movie I can't lick my eyes
Oh gross
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was something special that was
really cool it was great
wait wait mr. hi more as in time or the
other game time or as in the game that
spawned the animation from cranbersher
about time or oh my god it did wow
that's crazy that was great
that was a fantastic horror game
phenomenally even wonderful I love that
that was fantastic
really well done I enjoyed that
incredibly ha I don't know if there were
more secrets to find I doubt there were
but if there were then there's a link in
the description below where you can find
this game and play it for yourself I got
nothing else to say that was spooky
all the way through it had plenty of
good scares and a lot of just creepy
ambiance
and you can't ask for more nor again
absolutely wonderful loved it so yeah
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more scary games they
are as always linked in the description
Lix iam show licks iam I'm sorry I'm
sorry I didn't mean to say your name
wrong I just it's late in the night I
I've been recording a while I've been
saying a lot of words I didn't mean no
no please no go back oh let's see them I
mean listen fine they're down the
description below I'm sorry but if you
also want to be notified of when I
upload new videos Hey subscribe and ring
the bell
it's very important you'll know when I
put up new videos thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]